This economic impediment was the basis for
the Health Information Technology for Economic and Clinical Health Act,
abbreviated Hi Tech, a part of the American Recovery and Reinvestment Act of 2009,
commonly called the Stimulus.
The details are complex,
but there were three basic elements of the program: First there was HIT certification,
that defined minimum functional requirements for EHRs and other clinical tools.
Second, there was meaningful use,
which defined the minimum use to which hospitals and providers must put their EHR.
Third, there were incentive payments made to
hospitals and providers for adopting a certified EHR,
and meeting the requirements of meaningful use.
These programs are of course interdependent,
and do not apply to all providers,
only hospitals and providers that participated in Medicare or Medicaid,
adopted a certified EHR,
and used it according to the prescriptions in meaningful use were eligible to
receive incentive payments in 2011 through 2015.
Incentive payments came to hospitals and providers
through their participation in either Medicare or Medicaid.
Providers could be eligible only for one,
but hospitals could be eligible for both.
There were annual limits to the amount of
the payments and the total amount that a provider
could earn depended on when that provider achieved the stages of meaningful use.
As of October 2015,
more than 479000 health care providers received incentive